三个三堂课是不是很充实
很饱满
我可是卯足了劲跟大家传授我所有的功力
我想说课堂结束之后
我应该很衰弱
所有的内力都传送给你们的
所以你们要好好的吸收好不好
这堂课讲的是歌词创作里的仪式感
以诗的语法为标杆
我们先立定一个目标
我们的歌词它的语法结构要有点像心思那样子
因为心思的语法跟他跳跃式的思考
基本上会比绝大多数的歌词来得深刻
而且意境会比较丰富
这样子的去创作歌词的话会有好处
起码你的歌词里面会有几句
是让人家眼睛一亮的句子
记得歌词参与评比的时候很重要
一定要让评委有眼睛一亮的佳句
纵使你通篇不是很出彩
甚至有点平庸
但是你只要一两句佳句
在每一个段落都有布局
我真的告诉你
反而他会因为加剧而觉得你这整首不错
记得哦
要让你的鸽子看得下去
那看得下去最好的方式就是你前面的a one
有一两句的语法结构
让人家眼睛为之一亮
那最好的方法就是类心思画
所以呢歌词创作里的仪式感
下一行就是意心思的语法结构为标杆去追求
把定为一种目标
其实仪式感可以体现在我们生活的方方面面
最简单最好的例子是生日
每个人都要过生日吧
好某年某月是你的生日
然后大家都庆祝给大家聚会的一个理由跟借口
但是生日是人为的
365天是人定的
你去年2月2号过生日
举个例
今年2月2号过生日
那你的生日可能是20年前
30年前的那个2月2号
在宇宙的时间
基因纬度来讲
这些日子是不相关的
但是人为把它划分的
以太阳的地球公转划分成一年
给我们聚会的时候一个强而有力的借口
你也可以说这种仪式感哦
我的生日到了
大家聚集起来
你无缘无故吆喝朋友们聚会
有些人可能推三阻四
有些可能肚子痛
然后临时加班什么的
但是生日大家都觉得一年才一次
出席的几率会非常的高
就像婚礼一样嘛
多数人只结一次婚嘛
所以呢婚礼参与的几率更高
这个就是仪式感
重视仪式感会让你的生活讲究而不将
就像那种流水席
户外那种帆布架的那种婚宴
不是说不好
他很接地气
但是婚就结这么一次嘛
你难道不能慎重一下吗
大家穿戴如意
然后我的穿着代表我对这个婚礼的重视
像日本的一些樱花季
可能所有的女生可能就穿和服或所谓的浴衣
这个就是代表我对这个节庆的一个重视
我用我的穿戴去反映我对这个节庆的一种仪式
日本是个很重视仪式感的民族
他可能有茶到
有花道
有剑道
有书道
各个领域都是一种流派
这样子会让你的生活很精致
有个追求
这是好事
像我也是很重视仪式感
这个区块体现在我收藏方面的话
就是非常的个人的那种生活细节的收藏
因为我觉得如果自己是一个朝代
那你那些演唱会的票根呐
那些入场券呐
机票的票根就是你这个朝代的一些史料
我是从国小开始说起
一直到现在出社会了
然后一些奖项啊
一些出席活动的吊牌啊
我都留着
这个就是仪式感
生活细节的仪式感
这样子的话会让你的生活有一种节奏
这种节奏会让你的生活精致化
就很像我们吃东西
看到日本的摆盘
合适的料理
每个食物都有自己相对应的网盘
这种方式是视觉上很享受
慢慢的吃吃
而不是大杂烩的混在一起
这个就是饮食上的仪式感
所以呢仪式感是体现在方方面面
可能元宵节就打个灯笼
中秋节可能就吃月饼
这也是仪式感的一部分
所以记得仪式感会让你的生活有点细节
体现在文字上
也是这个仪式感体现在文字创作上
特别是歌词的领域
还有五个执行的区块
分别是画面态度情感情绪
故事线
首先我用一首歌词来当范例
听爱画面态度情感情绪
故事线好
我们先来看听爱这首歌的画面感在哪里
山南飘去
山坳下潺潺野溪
雏菊迎风在遥役淮南王在此写下一页传奇
关于豆腐的秘密
因为这是量身定做的电影主题曲
所以有些关键字是委托方所事先设定的
一定要尊重委托方的请托或是要求
因为我们的流行音乐
所谓的歌词创作是为了听歌的人唱歌的
或某一个影视专案而服务
所以他们有些关键字
关键词要放在歌词的字里行间
那是非常合理的一个要求
就像拍广告一样
你接了个汽车广告
然后业主希望我的汽车凸显了我的门
打开的声音很好听
或是速度感
或是后视镜有什么样的遥控
你导演一定要去符合对方的要求吧
你可以在对方的约束下
尽尽可能的帮你的原创性做一个发挥
这样才是功利
记得哦
而不是没有任何的束缚
照你的意念去创作
那太容易了
就像先有词一样
先有词后有曲一样
如果完全不顾虑到委托方的一个需求
那天马行空的去做自己的创意
那太潇洒了
这样子的歌词不是所谓的功力的展现
真正的功力的展现是在对方的约束下
在对方的要求下
你还能把创意做最大限度地发挥
你要尊重你的工作
你就要交出你的专业
交出对方的期待
也因此他们的关键字可能就是淮南王豆腐
因为这个动漫跟豆腐有关
画面感山南山凹下潺潺野西
其实画面感对我来讲经营上不是很困难
因为我很会经营画面感
记得只要几个关键字就可以把画面感给点出来
就是符合歌词的一种结构的布局
布局的巧妙就会油然而起画面感
而画面感来自于关键字a one的
关键字可能就是雏菊
山南野西
画面感有了好
第二大段一派宁静的这里
豆腐浓郁的香气飘在寻常巷弄里
巷弄也是画面感
这是我所深爱的豆香
永不放弃
是史册从无记载的梦境哦
这边做点小创意
史册没有记载这样子的所谓的故事或仙境吧
你就可以把它形容成梦境
史册没有记载的梦境
那你的创意就是在这里发挥
接下来就比较口语了
你的声音听见爱情
这个其实是情感
刚开始是酝酿画面
画面是帮故事定调
把他的时间轴跟场合空间定掉
这里的态度可能要通篇看完歌词才知道
他有一个态度
在这个态度呢可能就是focus在这个动画上面
至于情感跟情绪
它是大范围跟小范围
首先你的声音听见爱情
这是情感
很明显哦
这应该有情歌的成分
再来这得道成仙如浮云
名利成灰烬
爱已飘零
谁能够为我解释这命运
有点感叹哦
有点哲学的意味哦
哦大概知道了
这样子的态度跟情感已经很明显
这古镇斑驳老墙爬满了绿
这个画面感又十足了
树下有人在下棋
这很美哦
那么古镇啊
村口啊有一些老者啊地方的祈祷
这边下棋哇
这个远远拍
很漂亮
这世外桃源有你
故事落笔
我比谁都要入戏
因为有他喜欢的人在这里哦
OK故事落笔了
我比谁都入戏
我愿意进来了哦
这是感情的戏
所以我比谁都入戏哦
这个就是情绪了
而不是情感
它比较细节
记得情感跟情绪不一样
红尘缘分如目的
我为什么要加个木木桶的木
因为他是乡村的调性
你说红尘景色如长笛
很奇怪
红尘景色如洞箫
就画面感觉怪了哦
穆迪哦
整个focus在乡村
深深思念
隔距离
这个有点失的语法
为什么人一定是离开才能思念嘛
你不肯这个人就在你旁边
那你还看着他的思念
就很奇怪了嘛
对不对
可能看着他很心动吧
或心跳吧
所以一定这个人可能某个时空离开你
或是离你没有那么的近
所以叫层层思念
隔距离想你落泪
被默许
仍在水墨如画的故里轻轻叹息
你是我越沉越浓的回忆
这也是情绪哦
再来你的声音听见爱情
这就是副歌了
副歌的记忆点副歌记得很口语哦
就像刚刚那个你的声音听见爱情
如果你通篇这个
那可能第一关就等就是灯
就就按那个打叉的灯了
歌词的语法结构
你可以有漂亮的句子在某一个段落穿插就够了
然后副歌有时候是记忆点
有时候反而副歌是最口语的哦
因为通常一段音乐下来
你哼哼唱唱的时候
通常大家只会哼那个副歌而已
就哼那么两段还背得下来嘛
所以有时候我刻意会副歌
让他更情绪化
更口语比较深的歌词用语
我反而会放在别的角落
整个把他拉抬上来
把他的水平拉抬上来
但是副歌我就很放心
很大胆的用口语的
因为因为我别的段落很强
我别的段落的歌词很强
就把整个歌词提升上来
那我副歌的第一行纵词很口语
也没有关系
记得这是搭配交错的使用好
我们继续你的声音
听见爱情
这得道成仙如浮云
因为是副歌嘛
所以两行都重复
加深记忆
点名利成灰烬
爱已飘零
谁能够为我解释真命运
这是整段都重复的
这也是可以的哦
很多种方式哦
好接下来最后一行
你的叮咛听见爱情有没有
这是听爱嘛
所以你的叮咛听见爱情
你的声音
听见爱情
听见爱情这四个字没有变
变成你的声音
你的叮咛可以换
前面的有一些变化是千年一豆的宿命
他毕竟是动漫嘛
focus在豆腐是千年一斗的命运
繁华都归零
你在安静
我是等生根发芽的真心
真心要生根发芽哦
你看他盘踞都多深
我漂亮的句子
俊永的句子用在这里就够了
生根发芽的真心
他不是浮萍
漂浮着无依无靠
不是的
三男野溪雏菊
他怎么会有情绪呢
不会有情感跟情绪
情感是大范围
这两个人是互相喜欢的
然后情趣是小细节
譬如像刚刚举的例子哦
这世外桃源有你
故事落笔
我比谁都要入戏
这个就是情绪很浓稠的地方
最后是故事线
这个故事线也很容易理解
它带有点奇幻的意味
有没有得道成仙呐
哪弄世外桃源呐
你只要文字的画面经营得好
他的故事线自然会形成
而且故事线有时候是依赖着情绪跟情感
去强化它
记得哦
这个五个要诀
画面态度
情感情绪故事线
接下来我们再以另外一首来当做范例
这首叫千里之外
屋檐如悬崖
风铃如沧海
我等燕归来
这个其实画面感很饱满
然后再来时间被安排演一场意外
你悄然离开
第二行完全没有画面感哦
再来故事在城外浓雾散不开
看不清对白哦
城外浓雾又有画面感了
第四行
你听不出来
风声不存在
是我在感慨哎第四行又没有画面感了
好再来
最后的ending是梦
醒来是谁在窗台把结局打开
那薄如蝉翼的未来
经不起谁来拆
薄如蝉翼
你看那个蝉
夏天那个蝉的蝉翼是很细微
你你这么细微的未来
谁都不敢猜
怕拆坏了
只是比喻说未来谁都不敢碰
很不明确
心悬在那里
我送你离开千里之外
你无声黑白
千里之外就是记忆点
就是歌的名字
这首歌是最自私的命名法
就是最有基点的
副歌的第一行的关键字拿来当歌的名字
就是千里之外好
第二行
沉默年代或许不该太遥远的相爱
我送你离开天涯之外
你是否还在
我就换一个语词哦
反正是千里之外
好像换天涯之外
琴声何来
生死难猜
用一生去等待秦深海去对仗
生死难猜啊
接下来这个歌词的语法就很美
我当初创作的当下自己也很喜欢
那我朗诵给各位同学分享
闻泪声入林寻梨花白
只得一行青苔
天在山之外雨落花台
我两鬓斑白
然后另外是重复了闻泪声入林寻梨花白
只得一行青苔
然后再来就换了
天在山之外
雨落花台
我等你来
这个其实是很有画面感的
你看喽
听到有人哭泣的声音
进入了一个树林里面
或者所谓的森林里面去寻找这个哭声在哪里
闻泪声入林
他是用这个哭声去吸引它
它进去了
闻泪声入林
寻梨花
白走走
走到最后哎
他找不到哭声
只看到满地的梨花
而只看到因为树林被阳光所遮蔽
长满了青苔
只得一行青苔
我两鬓斑白
他就是砸到最后也没找到人
这时间的跨轴很长
有点像夸式
他两鬓的鬓角已经斑白了
就是可能找的时间岁月让他有白头发了
这是一个夸式的一个形容词
就对了
就说你去经营文字的结构的时候
你会顺着羽翼的方向去走
有时候是歌词的语义牵着你走啊
像这段歌词基本上是羽翼带着我走的
是闻泪声
入林寻梨花白
只得一行青苔
天在山之外
雨落花台
我两鬓斑白
就是走着走着诶好像是有点残学哲学的意味
在歌词的意境里面
这个就是我刚刚强调的歌词创作中的仪式感
以新思语法结构为标杆
这样的语法的跨境词句之间的跨径是大的
内容物是丰满的
这样子的创作人家就会很容易记住你了
像我们现在所创作的流行音乐
基本上是依附着简谱或五线谱而去填词
所以我一直强调
大多数的状态下是先有曲后有词
所以作者也叫填词
那想想看
那古代人呢怎么办
我们中国并没有发明五线谱啊
他们有所谓的减字谱
接下来跟各位同学分享
一个很特别的一个采谱方式
不要说你国风歌曲写了老半天
人家问你
哎你剪字谱知道吗
你从头到还不晓得这个讯息
那就尴尬了
只能说尴尬了
因为你既然从事流行音乐的创作
你既然从事歌词领域的创作
那居然从头到尾没有听过
我们老祖宗的一个采谱方式
叫简字谱
所以呢今天介绍给大家
你虽然不必理解
但是知道他的
大概我觉得起码代表你这个圈子哦
有一些触类旁通
一些跟音乐相关的知识都稍微懂了一点点
我把古代的古琴谱
明代的叫青湖琴谱
我把青湖琴谱里面的简字谱彩字
我所采的简字谱等于就是菊花台的音符
如果你会弹古琴的话
你照这个简字谱弹
弹完它就是菊花台的旋律
是不是很特别
因为古琴有七弦13徽位
那这是执法谱
就说你的手按哪里勾哪里
它上面有载明
然后勾跟暗的方式
它把很多汉字集合在一起
但是结合在一起笔画又太多
他就把简化简化就变成简字谱
所以你看到线条很多
他其实已经简化过了
他的意思说你左手按哪里勾哪里
然后右手按哪里勾哪里
他把所有的指法都集中在一个字
说明你才能发出一个音呢
所以它叫简字谱
很特别
就是古代的一个古琴演奏的一个方式
流行音乐的生命就是建立在传唱上
它如果没有流通跟传唱
它基本上没有被创造的必要
你就不需要写这首歌了嘛
因为根本没有人听过
或者是他根本不具流通性
那我就在思考一个问题
那如果这个歌词脱离了旋律
他还能有生命力吗
他有什么表情呢
他有什么支撑着它存在呢
我想到立体的装置艺术
也因此我用透明的树脂
把这些简字谱包覆在里面
做成一个很大的算是雕塑品
象征着说
把菊花台的故事封印在这个雕塑品里面
它永远不会老化
它永远不会老去
这个故事这个委婉的故事
这样子一个凄美的旋律
它被永远的封印了
它也是象征着我做的一个尝试
就是文字脱离了音乐
他会用何种的面目去呈现
这个就是我之前的一个作品跟大家分享
那之所以跟大家分享
这个就是说歌词的创作可以有无限的可能
记得你可以歌词创作之外
你也写写新诗
你也可以写写散文
甚至你也可以做雕塑品
装置艺术都有可能
不要说好像只有一条出路而已
不是的
眼界要放宽
要放远
但是先决条件是你的基础要好
你的基础要打得深
像我在流行音乐圈待了20几年
20几年后我才开始创作这种装置艺术
把歌词装置艺术化
你总不能待个一两天就开始创作吧
起码你的歌要有生命力
要有传唱度
要有共鸣
所以呢跟各位同学提醒
是真的把或目标去追求
你就要沉得住气
你就要有耐心
在这个圈子里面好好的呆
好好的把每一堂课都做笔记
因为这堂课很特别
不是纯粹只教你歌词创作而已
但是所有的课程都是包覆着歌词创作
提供你养分
可能讲书法
可能讲建筑
可能讲美学
然后可能讲装置艺术
但是最后回馈的就是
想要让你的歌词的创作更有人文调性
意象更万千更饱满
所有呈现出来的作品的形式更与众不同
定一个目标
我的歌词就是有诗的水平
那起码你定目标定的高
定的远
你就算没有达到
往后退也是接近吧
你不能一下子的目标定很近哦
我只要看起来像鸽子就好了
那我告诉你
如果有竞争
如果有筛选
如果比赛的话
那你是第一个被淘汰的人
记得一开始设定的目标就要够远够深
眼睛要看得够宽
加油咯